priyanka i have been wanting to read
your memoir unfinished for
so long now did it and girl i mean i was
zooming through it like crazy i was all
sorts of emotions i was tears laughter
joy it was so great congratulations
but pre you are all of 38 years old and
you already have a memoir written
so why did you want to capture
this point of your life in a memoir
which is why i called it unfinished
first of all thank you for reading it
you're so
sweet and thank you for liking it it's
the first time i've written so i was
terrified i still am
um but i think i was just introspective
at a time when i think everyone was
introspective we were all at home and it
was
you know it's been daunting i wrote this
book pretty much predominantly in
quarantine um but i was approaching 20
years in the entertainment business
and um you know i was like i wanted to
commemorate that i've always wanted to
write but i was scared of structured
writing like
a book or like a screenplay um
but i i wanted to attempt it i always
like to push myself to do something i've
not done you know creatively
it's great to keep evolving but because
i wrote it during quarantine it became
as personal as it i guess is you know i
didn't
expect to be scratching beneath the
surface as much as i did
i'm looking forward to like breaking
some of these things down with you today
first though your account of your
journey to miss world
as a former miss usa myself like i felt
like i could totally relate
i found it interesting that you said
well pageants were
highly competitive which they are in a
sense you didn't feel like they fully
prepared you for
hollywood how so because it's just
completely different things
i thought you know like coming from a
family that was
that's not an entertainment family right
i didn't know what it means to
be famous or to be in a public position
where people you know want to know about
you and everyone knows who you are
and then when movies came to me because
i was known by them as miss world i was
like oh that should be easy
yeah but it's not it's a job it's a
craft
it's being able to embody creatively
with your physicality
someone completely different than you
that's it's so hard
and then on top of that add the public
pressure add the
um you know always being under a
microscope everything you do sort of
being
debated discussed like you know your
choices
being judged um everything being
dissected
at 18 it was just like it did not
prepare me
that kind of limelight and being miss
world it would never
have prepared me for this crazy ride
called entertainment this is
another ball game it definitely is that
is
now you know so interesting reading and
i was
completely shocked that once you entered
into
you know hindi films and and things of
that sort in
india you were you went to a meeting
with the director
he told you you're gonna have to get
multiple surgeries a breast augmentation
if you ever want to succeed in this
business honey
he made you twirl for him you also went
as far as to
in one project you quit because of the
tone of the director
and and how he wanted to sexualize you
in the project
how do you feel like you didn't fall
prey to
insecurities that can come about in this
industry i did
because as much as i may have walked
away from that project because of how he
spoke about me or spoke to me he didn't
see me as an artist
bringing something to the table he saw
me as an object for titillation that's
it
that's all i was there for and it just
makes you feel small
as much as i walked away from the movie
because it made me feel that way
i didn't do anything about it i didn't
say anything about it
because i had to work within the system
so i put my head down and i worked
within the system
and i think i why did i do that because
i had insecurities i was scared i was
trying to fix you know like
make a career at that point i didn't
want it to be taken away from me and you
know girls are we're told that
you don't want to attract the wrong kind
of attention you don't want to
be hard to work with you know you've got
to like
smile and everything's alright and i did
that for a really long time because i
was insecure you know and it's okay to
be insecure i think
no one's perfect no one can live in a
black or a white
i think everyone lives in gray and it's
okay
as much as we can you know we should try
and walk towards
what is right for your heart and what is
right for your soul and it's okay to be
insecure through it i
have been and i continue to be every
time i do a new thing i'm terrified of
this book coming out it's the first time
i'm writing
you know every time i pivot i'm insecure
and scared and like
you know and it's and i've you i've
accepted that about
my nature that it's okay to do that
but unfortunately whenever you first got
your start in the u.s
you did i could not believe that you
experienced a series of
xenophobia bullying verbal attacks uh
because of your background how much of a
toll did that take on you at the start
of your career here in the us
you know it's so like i've been working
in america now for about 10 years
acting just about five so it's so recent
too that it blows my mind i know
but it's not like two decades ago or
something it's like
now it's crazy you know um
at that time it terrified me because i'd
never
like i didn't i couldn't understand it
um i didn't know where it was coming
from i didn't think it was warranted i
was just making music
you know i was like it's so innocent
yeah it was just a song
just because i'm a public person or you
know you can
do i deserve that like just oh you
didn't look where you are now
you know yeah and it's just it's just i
wish that you know on socials as well
and i know a lot of people deal with
this with
just negativity and general hate that is
spewed on socials i wish people would
use it for what it was actually made for
which is to be social you know exactly
it's so funny that you mentioned social
media because i do believe that's how
you and mr nick jonas met miss prix
well he did slide into my dms he did he
split into your team
and i love how you just talk about your
love story with nick
and at what point did you know that nick
jones
was the one actually i went to the
studio on our third i didn't know
he was the one for i don't know when i
found out but i was just riding this
giant wave he was
this tornado that kind of just took over
my life
and up until then i was
you know coming in and out of a a very
tumultuous time in my life i was you
know
i just moved to the us i was kind of sad
i was dealing with like a lot of grief
and
a lot of and he just came into my life
at a point where i had chosen
me i was happier i was healthier i was
in a great
state of mind and he was like a
hurricane and i just kind of went with
it
and you know that's sort of our dynamic
even now
i have a lot of faith in who my husband
is and i know
i have a lot of faith in the rock that
he is for
our family and you know that's such a
great feeling to be able to like lean on
someone and know that they got you
it's so happy to see you in this good
thing this healthy loving relationship
free
and i think so many people will be able
to relate to
you saying how perfect your wedding
celebrations were but how much you
deeply missed your father being there
because your father passed
of cancer before you and nick got
together but what do you think your dad
would think of nick and how happy he'd
be
for the relationship that you're in
right now i think he would be
very happy for i think he'd be very
happy for the play simon
right now he always wished for me to um
you know feel a sense of contentment
and um and i do i feel a sense of
um self at the moment with myself
professionally where i am the work that
i'm doing the work that i'm creating and
that's my
big baby you know you don't know what
the next thing is you don't know where
your next check's coming from you don't
know what your next job is
it's a constant hustle but i feel like
at a place where
i have um you know faith in my ability
what i bring to the table so i think my
dad would have been really happy about
that and the fact that i have a partner
who um not only appreciates it but
pushes that
that side of me i think my dad would
have really loved that